[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el 2022
avanza y se presenta como un año con
múltiples en retos para la región de
américa latina- el desafío de la
pandemia del cobi 19 persiste y será un
tema transversal para todos los países
de la región que además deben hacer
frente a las diferentes situaciones a
las particulares que se les va a ir
presentando a lo largo de este año
algunos de los países van a tener
elecciones presidenciales que podrían
marcar un nuevo rumbo político en
general la región tendrá que hacer
frente a una profunda crisis económica
al desempleo la crisis de la deuda y
también el malestar social también será
el año en el que podríamos estar ante la
consolidación de ciertos modelos de
gobierno en algunos países determinados
será un año de desafíos en materia
medioambiental de derechos humanos
migración y la lucha contra el crimen
organizado hoy en el debate de france 24
el panorama general de américa latina'
de cara al 2022 es nuestro tema de
análisis para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a mauricio jaramillo
lista internacionalista y también
profesor de relaciones internacionales
de la universidad del rosario en la
ciudad de bogotá en la capital
colombiana también está con nosotros
gaspar tapia el cientista político y
analista internacional latinoamericano
está conectado con nosotros desde la
ciudad de santiago en chile ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en el debate con todos los
comentarios y las preguntas sobre este
tema lo pueden hacer a través de las
redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook en instagram también en twitter
como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal le
desean recuerdo que la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas
comienzo entonces con mauricio que fue
el primer invitado que presenté como lo
decía él está en la ciudad de bogotá y
comienzo haciéndole la pregunta de
apertura a la discusión un panorama
general mauricio bienvenido al programa
y en líneas generales
cuáles van a ser esos hechos que va a
estar enfrentando la región de américa
latina' las dificultades los momentos
que podemos estar viendo en los próximos
meses a lo largo de este año bienvenido
muchas gracias santiago un saludo
gracias por la invitación yo empresaria
que como tres líneas en términos
generales en en primer lugar hay dos
procesos electorales que serán
determinantes para el futuro de américa
latina brasil y colombia tienen mucho
que ver en primer lugar porque son
gobiernos de derecha que han desgastado
un poco el discurso
neoconservador
y esto además no tiene un efecto en muy
seguramente en la correlación de fuerzas
de izquierda a derecha en la zona en
segundo lugar tenemos temas que han
golpeado américa la tiene en el último
tiempo uno es el de la migración en
venezuela
y américa central etcétera la
inmigración que no era necesariamente un
tema relevante la agenda latinoamericana
en el último tiempo se ha convertido en
un tema inexorable digamos no solamente
en los escenarios micros sino que el
tema es cada vez más importante hay que
recordar a la gente que venezuela es el
país hoy del mundo con un mayor número
de desplazados incluso por encima de
siria y terminaría diciendo que un
tercer tema que va a ser importante
latina
obviamente por lo que pasa en venezuela
la oposición ha anunciado que va a
empezar un proceso de revocatoria de
mandato contra nicolás maduro y esto
sugiere pues básicamente dos caminos o
bien que la oposición siga por este
camino de deshacerse de maduro que se
retomen un poco el tema de la
negociación y que sea un tema digamos
doméstico o interno pues es un tema que
de dos maneras por cita en interés de
américa latina en resumidas cuentas
mauricio procesos electorales la
migración y la situación política en
venezuela serían los tres temas para
destacar desde su punto de vista veamos
que dice gabriel tapia en la ciudad de
santiago bienvenido al programa gabriel
y cuáles serían sus impresiones en
líneas generales del panorama de nuestra
región para este nuevo año porque muchas
gracias por invitación una aclaración mi
nombre es gabriel gaspar
perfecto
que toda américa latina tiene un piso
común de 2 proceso que la que la
atraviesan uno es el
de la pandemia con todo su vaivén en
cada país de cómo se administra y unido
y explicando la también está el tema de
la recesión económica que ella ha
provocado y bueno las cuarentenas el
cierre de actividades y esto es un piso
común para todos los países de américa
latina
enfrente esta situación que genera mucha
precariedad y muchas dificultades a la
población este en general demanda
protección social y protección social es
medida en
expresar medidas contra el desempleo
social en materia de salud protección
social en materia de previsión etcétera
y la realidad también preexistente es
que merced a un modelo de privatización
y de regulación y achicamiento del
estado que más o menos se da en casi
todos los países la sector en las becas
anteriores en los mecanismos de
protección social del estado son muy
débiles y han tenido que sobre la marcha
reacción y bueno con distintos
resultados podríamos decir que a eso se
suman los temas
habituales de la región yo iría en este
caso la emigración compartiría mucho con
lo que hijos mauricio
haciendo no señalados la migración no es
9 en américa latina pero la diferencia
es que antaño la emigración era
básicamente de sur a norte
vale decir era desde la cuenca del pan y
del caribe de centroamérica caribe y
méxico en particular hacia eeuu
en la diferencia en que se valora es que
la crisis venezolana es querer una
excursión de población que abarca a
virtualmente todo el continente y en
particular a sudamérica
gabriel desde la ciudad de santiago en
chile bueno ya lo decía yo en la
introducción el tema de la pandemia de
kobe 19 sigue vigente seguimos haciendo
frente a esta emergencia a nivel global
y va a ser un tema transversal que le
concierne a todos los sistemas de salud
de toda la región de américa latina
la variante omicron sigue avanzando y en
este tema también vimos desigualdades
países que avanzaron muy bien en el tema
de la vacunación en la prevención tipo
chile uruguay países que se quedaron un
poco rezagados países como cuba que
pudieron desarrollar sus propias vacunas
a nivel local y las dificultades que se
ha venido presentando que panorama
podemos analizar en torno a lo que nos
puede traer la pandemia que es
completamente incierto lo sé pero
comienzo preguntándole a mauricio este
tema cómo va a afectar entonces a la
región y cómo va a afectar esto a nivel
político ya llevamos dos años de
pandemia y ya vemos consecuencias claras
yo creo que la pandemia va a seguir
siendo importante pero no creo que sea
el tema definitivo este año creo que
sobre todo en términos políticos los
aspectos que iba a tener la pandemia me
parece que están relativamente superados
aunque aquí nadie sabe que puede pasar
en términos de salud por ejemplo es muy
poco probable que se vuelvan a retrasar
procesos electorales como pasó en chile
como pasó en bolivia es muy poco
probable que los gobiernos vuelvan a
acudir a decretos de emergencia o que se
presenten situaciones de polarización
como la que vivió la propia colombia yo
creo que si bien la pandemia va a seguir
siendo un tema importante de política
pública el tema que va a marcar la
agenda es el que señalaba a mi mi colega
gabriel que tiene que ver con la
reactivación pero yo no veo digamos una
pandemia que siga teniendo un efecto
político como lo vimos en 2020 y 2021 y
que condiciona de alguna manera los
procesos electorales los procesos
políticos me parece que ya la región
tiene una inercia propia estamos pasando
más en postpandemia se habla de la
vacunación la vacunación hoy está mucho
menos politizada lo que estuvo en 2021
entonces me parece que por lo menos en
términos
no hablo en términos sanitarios no veo
un efecto muy digamos representativo de
la pandemia y gabriel su opinión al
respecto
bueno
diré que la pandemia desgraciadamente
llegó para quedarse y para ir mutando en
distintas formas que no sabemos cuándo
va a terminar
y por tanto hay que tomarla como un dato
más ahora como le enfrentan cada país
cualquier estrategia etcétera bueno eso
es diferente y aquí en lo personal uno
podría echar de menos unas
coordinaciones básicas de entre los
distintos países porque indudablemente
la pandemia no es un tema de un solo
países ni siquiera de la región es un
tema global y los países
latinoamericanos hemos sido incapaces
hay que decirlo juntos palabras
en poder coordinar formas de cooperación
básica por ejemplo
que toda la región o algún grupo
pudiéramos negociar formas de contratos
y compromisos con los grandes
laboratorios que obviamente en cada
entregado cada una a su dimensión ya su
suerte no todos tienen las mismas
posibilidades y allí
cabría decir que con esto incluido que
los mecanismos de coordinación regional
los mecanismos internacionales de
américa latina han sido absolutamente
inoperantes pueden haber muchas razones
pero no han cumplido una coordinación
básica que decir incluso de un
tratamiento conjunto al tema la
migración
entonces estamos ante una pandemia que
va a ser constante llevado a cambiar de
va a multar la reactivación económica
por tanto va a seguir con dificultades y
frente a eso la respuesta de américa
latina va a ser disgregada
desgraciadamente salvo que el otro
gobernante reaccione
y gabriel para redondear este tema de la
pandemia porque tengo que abordar
diferentes temas para la región es un
tema muy amplio
si algo nos recordó la pandemia del cobi
19 y nos ha recordado hasta el día de
hoy porque era algo que ya sabíamos que
estaba ahí pero no nos hizo memoria es
la precariedad de los sistemas de salud
de la región y la presión que están
recibiendo por los diferentes picos de
la pandemia esto el tema de la salud
para la región pasará a ser algo
prioritario a raíz de esta pandemia
ahora que los gobiernos están un poco
más tranquilos podrán ponerse a pensar y
darle prioridad sobre todo en estos
países donde hay procesos electorales
podría entrar a ser un tema importante
yo diría que la sociedad latinoamericana
no están muy tranquilas desde no tenía
mi diagnóstico pero en segundo lugar la
salud es una prioridad para todo
gobernante el problema es que en américa
latina en la mayoría de los países y con
intensidades distintas
buena parte de los servicios de salud se
privatizaron así la salud que es un
derecho constitucional en la mayoría de
los países se entregó a la gestión
privada a una parte de ella lo cual no
está mal pero se debilitó mucho lo
estatal con lo cual en la práctica se
cree una desigualdad para el siglo en
palabras sencillas con dinero se tiene
un buen seguro de salud sin dinero se
está sometido al sistema de salud
público que está muy de financiado y eso
se que era notorio desde antes la
pandemia se agudizó con el commit se
profundizó pasó a preguntarles ahora por
el tema de la economía la recuperación
económica la región la generación del
empleo la reducción de la pobreza que
sigue siendo una gran deuda pendiente en
la región américa latina' estiman va a
crecer 2 6% para el 2022 y un 27 por
ciento el 2023 después de que tuvo una
fuerte recuperación a pesar de todas las
dificultades durante el 2021 con una
recuperación promedio del 6 7 % son
solamente cifras como para darnos unas
ideas globales mauricio el tema de la
economía
perspectivas de lo que puede llegar a
ser para este 2022 opinión
bueno primero el estudio a bordo con
gabriel es una región que tiene muchas
asimetrías es decir no se puede hablar
por ejemplo de algunas de las economías
que hoy están incorporadas a los
circuitos internacionales con el caso de
chile con el caso de perú como en el
caso de médico hasta cierto punto
argentina y luego países que han
experimentado en el último tiempo un
rezago importante como el caso de haití
obviamente la crisis venezolana pues
merece un comentario aparte eso es lo
primero es una región asimétrica y lo
segundo es que por más de que haya
previsiones de crecimiento porque casi
todos los países van a crecer incluso
venezuela va a crecer por primera vez en
78 años en el desgaste social es muy
grande por la crisis económica la cepal
calcula 40 millones de nuevos pobres 45
millones de personas que van a perder
sus empleos y 8 millones más de personas
en pobreza extrema entonces esto implica
un poco el reto de lo que ya mencionaba
a gabriel de desmontar esta idea de que
el estado de su mínima expresión es una
buena idea
vamos a tener que volver a la época en
que el estado regulaba en que el estado
intervenía va a ser muy difícil que
américa latina se recupere si solo si
todos se dejan las manos del mercado acá
lo importante es que los estados digamos
que recuperen los sistemas sociales que
fueron denostados en la década de los 90
y se dejarán en manos de privados es
importante que en esto depende mucho lo
que pase con la economía global hay que
ver como como como sigue la crisis
sanitaria hay algunas zonas de américa
latina que dependen mucho del turismo y
algunas zonas de américa latina que
depende mucho de la demanda de materias
primas en en países como asia y como en
países de asia más bien como china y
como la india entonces hay factores si
se quiere internos y eso tienen mucho
que ver los procesos políticos y hay
factores globales veremos qué pasa con
la economía global a esto se le sumó me
toque un poco un poco información es la
atención que hay en torno a la
financiación en general en la mayoría de
los países y también el estrés que
tienen algunas economías de la región en
torno a el tema de la deuda aquí
podríamos poner un ejemplo muy claro y
es que enfrenta otra vez negociaciones y
enfrenta una complicada situación con la
deuda a nivel internacional gabriel su
opinión en temas en torno a lo económico
bueno yo lo primero que me nace es decir
que la recuperación de las cifras de
crecimiento del año 21 si bien son
positivas y se toman en consideración al
año anterior que es el 2020 en la cual
todos tuvimos una caída estrepitosa por
la haga por el coi claro y en la uar
entera en el cierre de la paralización
de faenas y labores entonces el domingo
21 más que un crecimiento es un rebote
producto de una
mejoría una liviana miento o un alivio
de las situaciones de cuarentena y de
inmovilidad que se produjo el por tanto
en el horizonte la reactivación y vuelvo
a señalar aquí que no es solamente un
tema puramente de economía
sino que también requiere un tipo de
acuerdos sociales con un acuerdo de
pacto social porque no se basta con
crecer sino también como se
redistribuyen los frutos de ese
crecimiento y ahí tenemos sociedades muy
disconformes y nuevamente las asimetrías
son grandes en este caso hay países como
argentina que tienen una deuda
gigantesca
impagable en estas condiciones con un
país que era clásicamente un país de
capas medias ideadas del país que tiene
arriba al 40 por ciento de pobreza y una
inflación de un 50 por ciento entonces
en la
situación de argentina es una situación
paradigmática digamos comparado con el
resto de la región
hay reacciones diversas y yo miro
algunos países de américa central
por ejemplo el salvador y ortega que si
bien tienen signos políticos muy
distintos coinciden en una conducta y es
que buscan el paraguas chinos se va a ir
distanciándose de su conexión con la
economía norteamericana no voy a juzgar
no voy a opinar en eso digo simplemente
es distintos es su trayectoria histórica
con relación al movimiento que están
haciendo y vamos a ver cómo les resulta
cada quien independiente del signo
político que tiene
en resumen la economía va a seguir
siendo un un desafío pero no solo como
reactivar la economía sino también como
redistribuir en medio de una sociedad
que está muy castigada en su capacidad
de consumo en su seguridad y bueno con
todo el malestar social que esto provoca
gabriel mauricio avanzó con otro tema de
la agenda y lo mencionaba mauricio en su
panorama general y es el tema electoral
hay tres procesos presidenciales
importantes costa rica colombia y brasil
costa rica es el primer país que va a
tener estos procesos este proceso
electoral en el mes de febrero es tal
vez una muestra de consolidación de su
sistema democrático
eligen también a vicepresidente xi a 57
diputados de la asamblea legislativa
colombiana tal vez es uno de los casos
más interesantes porque se debate entre
dos perspectivas políticas muy distintas
y brasil después entra de nuevo en la
escena política lula el legado que puede
dejar bolsonaro si puede aspirar o no a
esa a renovar sus votos y mantenerse en
la presidencia gabriel sus impresiones a
nivel electoral de lo que más allá de lo
que he destacado yo para la introducción
del tema lo primero caracterizar que
durante la vendimia ha tenido mucho el
proceso electoral en américa latina y
cambio de gobierno si hay una sola
constante porque yo escucho mucho el
péndulo pero es la única constante que
uno puede ver en todos los procesos los
resultados electorales es que los
partidos las fórmulas oficialistas han
sido derrotadas y eso vale para todas
las elecciones que se han hecho en la
región también destaca la estabilidad
que se dan algunos países pero que son
clásicamente los estables que es costa
rica y uruguay y lo cual habla no solo
en un proceso electoral estable sino de
una sociedad democrática estable y
republicana que es muy admirable y yo
creo que muy envidiable
respecto al tema de colombia yo me
gustaría más bien escuchar a mauricio
que tiene obviamente conoce mucho mejor
que
el servidor esa situación la pregunta a
mí es que habiendo segunda vuelta
las encuestas diría colocan a gustavo
petro en primer lugar pero no sé si en
segunda vuelta lograría mantener ese
primer lugar de una interrogante en el
caso de brasil
presidente el ex presidente lula marco
47 por ciento diría la encuesta mientras
el presidente usó nada marcó un byte
pues las elecciones son en octubre así
que como ya queda derecho y de que
octubre puede ser una eternidad en
materia políticas y las elecciones de
costa rica bueno son estables la única
novedad que yo veo la emisión a costa
rica que estaban muchos candidatos a
casi 20 y eso obviamente con un sistema
donde él gana el que obtiene a lo menos
40 por ciento de los votos se ve muy
difícil con esta dispersión entonces va
a haber segunda vuelta hitos mejor yo
creo que esperar aquí al que eso se
desenvuelva
mauricio su opinión
y yo yo coincido con lo que dicho
gabriel añadiría dos cosas lo primero la
elección brasileña creo que es muy
importante porque lo más probable es
como ya lo mencionaba ser el retorno del
partido de los trabajadores y esto puede
significar primero el retorno de brasil
o los espacios multilaterales de los que
se fue alejando paulatinamente con jair
bolsonaro esto puede implicar un nuevo
rol de brasil en la celac esto puede
representar un papel mucho más activo de
duración en el g22 como lo había
ocurrido desde que se restableció la
democracia a mediados de los 80 los me
parece que lo de brasil es mucho más
importante para la región que incluso
que para la misma política interna en
colombia por primera vez en la historia
desde que es democracia en colombia el
progresismo tiene un chance real de
llegar al poder como mencionaba gabriel
pues las encuestas le dan la victoria a
petro en la primera vuelta en la segunda
vuelta va a ser difícil por que
prevalecería un poco esta lógica que por
ejemplo
prevaleció en ecuador para derrotar a
andrés araus de todos contra
un poco que llegue a la izquierda al
poder
y creo que costa rica pues está marcada
por la fragmentación algo que ya
habíamos visto en otros escenarios de
américa latina' el propio perú por
ejemplo donde también había muchos
candidatos y nadie se perfiló en la
primera vuelta y finalmente por el
efecto rebote terminó ganando el pedro
castillo me parece que los tres procesos
demuestran un poco el descrédito de los
partidos tradicionales y un poco
elecciones que se llevan a cabo en
escenarios de enorme incertidumbre
manteniéndonos en el tema político en
mauricio qué
efecto puede generar esos procesos
electorales que hubo el año pasado usted
lo mencionaba el de perú y también el de
chile que marcó un cambio también una
alternancia en el poder todavía no no se
ha investido como presidente
oficialmente de gabriel boric pero lo
hará próximamente esto que puede generar
en estos procesos electorales que
tenemos para este año precisamente costa
rica y yo creería que más que todo
colombia viendo un poco el espejo de lo
que sucedió en chile y en perú como lo
vio usted y también aprovechó para
hacerle el resto de la pregunta que va
en torno a la consolidación si se le
puede llamar así de gobiernos como el de
ortega que se mantiene en el poder qué
va a pasar con nicaragua que va a pasar
con venezuela vamos tocando sus temas
para adentrarnos hacia esos dos casos
específicos
bueno yo pienso que lo primero es que en
américa latina hay muchas izquierdas
pero para no complicar la respuesta
diría que hay dos hay una tradicional
clásica que todavía cree que no debe
haber mercado que a veces en algunos
contextos coquetea con el autoritarismo
siendo los casos emblemáticos nicaragua
venezuela y cuba me parece que es una
izquierda que en el último tiempo se ha
cerrado y luego me parece que hay un
progresismo hoy que la izquierda
tradicional llega al poder en américa
latina es muy difícil es casi que
imposible y lo vimos tanto en la
elección de pedro castillo con la de
gabriel boric a los dos les tocó seducir
a muchos sectores de centro digamos que
a gabriel boric con él con el solo apoyo
del partido comunista no le hubiera
alcanzado a él le tocó acudir al partido
democracia democristiano al
medioambientalismo a marco enríquez
ominami con él con el progresismo no me
parece que esta izquierda su poco la que
está marcando la parada y creo que en el
último tiempo y lo digo también para los
escenarios de costa rica brasil y
colombia se ha desmontado santiago el
mito del castro-chavismo es decir la
izquierda
con castillo nos vamos a ver muy
seguramente con boris ha demostrado que
no necesariamente sigue el mismo libreto
de venezuela y aunque obviamente
intervenga el estado mucho más en el
mercado pues no tiene sentido las de
expropiaciones masivas nacionalización
darle la espalda al comercio
internacional en general estamos
hablando de una de una izquierda y un
progresismo mucho más abierto
y gabriel su opinión
comparto mucho esto de que es difícil
encasillar en un solo concepto a
múltiples alternativas políticas me
referente acaso a la izquierda porque
obviamente existe una izquierda de tipo
al va de la mano e incluso ahí hay
diferencias en tanto el modelo económico
pero sobre todo diría que ha sido un
rasgo común que usó los sectores más
conservadores de abrir la tienda en
distintas elecciones fue con la amenaza
de que si ganaban sus oponentes con
cualquiera sea lo que iba a pasar en
esos países de que hacer una remedio de
venezuela y el triunfo del comunismo
quiero aclarar una cosa
gabriel boric en los apoye a una
coalición de fuerzas
del frente amplio que un grupo de
partido en su mayoría muy nuevo de gente
muy joven en grupos ambientalistas y
también el partido como listas a no es
él ni el candidato en el partido
comunista
aunque obviamente los sectores
conservadores trataron de usar decía el
miedo del anticomunismo y lo que refleja
las elecciones del último tiempo si uno
mira las de bolivia las elecciones de
perú y la chilena es que ese ámbito ya
no resultó
porque porque hay otras alternativas
por ejemplo la experiencia de culpa en
la autorreferencia chilena pero aunque
estás o compones la experiencia y el
recuerdo en que deja el legado de
michelle bachelet de chile que es una
una alternativa que busca la inclusión
la paridad en la defensa del planeta y
la modernización y el mejoramiento de la
calidad de la democracia si es difícil
de por qué y cómo se llama desmontarla
con un anatema el tiempo de guerra fría
claro entonces en el caso particular ya
para cerrar con el tema de la
candidatura del boliche el presidente
electo tiene 35 años
nació creció después de la democracia no
conoció la dictadura no la apareció como
tampoco no padece otros no tiene es una
izquierda que no tiene ningún santuario
en ninguna otra capital ninguna otra
revolución
antigua que defender con todas sus
virtudes o sus problemas de oro y
también es una alternativa que conecta
muy bien con los desafíos actuales es la
defensa del planeta salvar el planeta y
la inclusión de género en la lucha
contra toda discriminación la apertura
cultural en fin que son temas más como
aquí la prensa la llama millennials sí y
que muestran un progresismo que va más
acorde y en mejor sintonía con los dos
tiempos de la sociedad
gabriel mauricio quiero que hagamos
pongamos la lupa en la región de
centroamérica porque hay tres casos muy
particulares
vemos el gobierno en la que él en el
salvador ampliamente criticado a nivel
internacional por estar socavando un
poco los valores democráticos de ese
país así lo dicen muchos analistas no lo
estoy diciendo yo honduras da un cambio
en materia política con la nueva
presidenta tomaran las riendas del país
y nicaragua pues gabriel ortega se
mantiene para un quinto período
presidencial
allí en ese país centroamericano sus
impresiones gabriel comienzo por usted
sobre el caso centroamericano estos tres
países
bueno ya que tenemos
algunas curiosas coincidencias por
ejemplo lo señaló al comienzo entre el
gobierno de
buques y de ortega hay enormes
diferencias ideológicas
un llama 1 es descargado el
ultraliberalismo y el otro es mucha más
partido de la agrupación del alba sin
embargo en su proyección internacional
coinciden porque buscan el alero chino y
se distancia en eeuu y en el caso de
honduras la alternativa que surge
más bien es una respuesta de una
sociedad que está agotada por la
violencia por las maras y por la
corrupción
son los ejes que explican el triunfo de
tomara en mi humilde opinión y contra
una fórmula de gobierno que el
presidente hernández que tiene problemas
de la justicia no con la justicia de
honduras en es con la justicia eeuu que
tiene un conjunto de
cargos y procesos que se desarrolla
entonces en lo que uno puede ver es una
una situación muy compleja que explica
también la violencia que explica la
migración una migración nueva porque
antaño la migración eeuu que no tiene
nada nueva era de hombres solos de
padres o en los hermanos mayores que de
allá regresaba pero lo que estamos
viendo hoy día son migraciones de
familias con células reales que ya no
sólo van a buscar el sueño americano
sino que van huyendo de la violencia en
su país por tanto hay una recomposición
en mi opinión del panorama político
centroamericano
desgraciadamente después de 30 años de
los acuerdos distintos de acuerdos de
paz que le pusieron el fin a esa guerra
ya voy llegando a la recta final del
programa mauricio su opinión sobre este
caso de centroamérica no antes de hablar
de venezuela y haití
y luego pensar y ahí comenzaría diciendo
que el caso nicaragua es el más
llamativo porque es el más definitivo
entra en una nueva etapa y creo que el
sandinismo abandonó definitivamente a
esta versión que tenía la década de los
80 que era un sandinismo compatible con
la democracia liberal y ahora empieza
una nueva fase que muy seguramente va a
terminar con una radicalización del
discurso y convirtiéndose rosario
murillo en la en la heredera del poder
luego me parece que honduras empezó un
nuevo ciclo un ciclo y catalogable como
progresista con consumara castro
honduras se une a estos nuevos gobiernos
que yo creo que no van a necesariamente
a acercarse al modelo venezolano van a
ser muy cautos y ahora que ver cuál es
el impacto que esto tiene en la política
regional ya con su esposo manuel zelaya
vimos una honduras muy cerca del alba el
que ahora ahorita gabriel pero yo
pensaría que habida cuenta de la
tragedia venezolana va a ser mucho más
cauta en política exterior como lo ha
sido por ejemplo gabriel boric o el
propio castillo en el perú y finalmente
en el salvador es un caso aterrador
porque eso no es un autoritarismo que ha
funcionado nadie bukele no solamente es
autoritario porque pues le ha metido la
mano a las cortes sino que además es un
presidente tremendamente popular y esto
sugiere que américa latina sigue siendo
una tierra fértil para los
autoritarismos me quedan dos minutos
para cerrar el programa quiero cerrar
tal vez con el caso más complicado que
es haití la crisis es a todo nivel
político económico social
medioambiental es muy difícil lo que
está sucediendo allí y también un poco
venezuela los retos que tiene
rápidamente mauricio para el cierre
muy rápidamente yo pensaría que lo que
tienes es escandaloso que todavía no
sepamos por qué quién mató a llueve en
el moisés y eso habla de las
dificultades enormes institucionales que
tiene en ti como estado y obviamente un
estado que salió de la agenda américa
latina' desafortunadamente y en segundo
lugar en venezuela
recordar que hay una reactivación
económica que está en curso el proceso
en méxico que va a ser clave para la
estabilidad de la región y una oposición
que sigue ganando terreno pues porque se
está unificando cada vez más y gabriel
lo dejo para el cierre sus impresiones
de haití y venezuela
bueno sobre ti yo creo que comparto
haití en la región el país más atrasado
en la región y con mayores dificultades
y con una institucionalidad muy precaria
y por tanto lo que corresponde a ir
nation building una reconstrucción de
nación en la cual tenemos que cooperar
todo porque en definitiva
es evidente que con sus propios recursos
con sus debilidades la sociedad y tiana
con hamás necesita de apoyo y ahí la
experiencia también de estos años re
hablando los años que operó la operación
de naciones unidas la minustah demostró
que muchas veces la cooperación los
distintos países destinan muchos
recursos pero estos recursos los
destinan condicionados condicionados a
que con esos refinancian operaciones es
para funcionarios o empresas ong de los
países donantes entonces esa práctica lo
que niega la cooperación es muy pocos y
sobre venezuela yo diría que hay que hay
un fenómeno
como el de
la recuperación económica al menos el
fin de la hiperinflación yo diría que lo
más notorio hay una fuerte organización
y hay situaciones políticas novedosas
como el triunfo en oposiciones varillas
y yo también diría que una oposición muy
día sin él
gabriel de identificación tan rotunda
con el presidente interino a guaita y se
nota que hay con chamba en recomposición
de liderazgos
gabriel gaspar y mauricio jaramillo
muchas gracias por haber hecho este
análisis para nuestra audiencia en
france 24 ustedes puede seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales a los dos
invitados les agradezco haber estado con
nosotros y a ustedes por la sintonía
siguen con nosotras
[Música]